how to get more confidence
the best way that i know how to get more
confidence is to start small usually if
you are unconfident in something it's
because
it's this big scary thing
that you've never done before i've never
had any success with before and because
it's so big and scary you doubt yourself
and you're not confident in your ability
to do it
and it it can be paralyzing and it shuts
you down the best way that i found that
helps me to be able to go out
and be confident in the things that i'm
doing is i start small i take that big
project
and i take it into small little pieces
and try to figure out okay that's my
long-term vision that's i'd love for
that to happen
but what's like the next little step
that i can take because that little step
is not as scary
and if i can do that then i know i can
do that step over and over and over
again and then i'm willing to go to the
next step and the next step and the next
step
some people
some people don't have this problem some
people are just overly confident all the
time
and
they just jump into new things
that's not me and that's not a lot of
people so if you're like that you could
turn off the video because it's not for
you
but if you are that kind of person and
you don't always have tons of confidence
going into every single situation
you can build up your muscle
by taking it into small steps because
the first time you do anything can be
scary and when it's scary you're unsure
the outcome you're unsure of your
abilities you don't have the confidence
but once you do it then you know you can
do it again and again and again you
could go one step up further
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers
mike who wrote in with a huge long
message thank you mike we gotta we gotta
work on cutting down our messages but
but it was a great email
basically wrote in to say he's
part of this life insurance company okay
he's got a brokerage him and his
father-in-law have this brokerage
together he's he's got 350 people under
him and his father-in-law wants him to
eventually take over the business
and mike is afraid that
he doesn't have what it takes to make
big decisions he's 26 years old i think
and he's afraid of taking over this
business and he's afraid to go talk to
his father-in-law to say hey
i don't know if i can handle this
mike
it's great that you're actually scared
here because
it shows that you care
it shows that you really care about the
350 people
who are under you and their livelihood
right you don't want to make the wrong
decision that could impact all of their
lives right put them out of business and
and make them go look for new jobs
so it's great and and that
that caring and compassion is a great
place to start
with for you to get more confidence
start making little decisions now
take over little chunks instead of
making these big wide ranging decisions
and having everything fall on your plate
have a transition period where you start
making more and more decisions and you
have your father-in-law as guidance
along the way in any major corporation
the person who becomes ceo doesn't just
become ceo overnight there's a grooming
process
they're trained they work with the ceo
they're mentored and they start taking
on responsibilities bit by bit by bit so
when they have the role they're
confident in it
so i'd encourage you to do the same
thing
and you could tell your father-in-law
and i wouldn't be too afraid to bring it
up
let him know that you you
are interested in this but you're
worried
and you want his help to train you to be
better and start taking on smaller
projects that work up to become bigger
projects
so the next time that comes up you're
able to handle it you have the
confidence to know that you can do it
okay it's believing in yourself and that
comes from getting some experience i
remember when i first started
doing videos
i was scared i was nervous that the
first videos were not great
i wanted to get into videos it was it
was a good reason i loved watching
videos i learned visually so i wanted to
create videos to help entrepreneurs it
was something i was passionate about
i just didn't have the confidence and i
wasn't really good at it and if you look
at my first videos they were they
weren't great they're still up on
youtube you can go back and watch them
they weren't fantastic
and
the first videos i made
i had to summon a lot of courage to do
it because standing in front of a camera
and knowing that what you record is
going to go out to millions of people
and being like public domain that was
scary and so i had to have things go a
certain way i had to be alone nobody
could be around me i had to have my
drink i had to have prepared and i did
so many takes it took me the whole day
to do one video
but i did it you know it wasn't great
but i did it and i knew that i could do
that again
and so i did it again and again and i
got better and better and better and
each time up the game a little bit
so now it doesn't matter if there's
people in the room it doesn't matter if
my day's gone a certain way it doesn't
take me all afternoon to make one video
but i couldn't have gone
from where i was to where i am now
without going through all those steps
and each step gave me confidence to take
the next step and the next step
i know it can be scary i know for any of
you who are watching who have
you have a goal that you want to reach
but it requires you jumping through a
lot of scary hoops and doing things that
are way outside your comfort zone
don't let that hold you back
don't let that hold you back from being
a great entrepreneur and helping a lot
of people
you can overcome those fears
and the best way again i know how to do
it is step by step so just break that
down into the smallest possible step and
start building momentum and start
getting better and better and as you
look back you'll say wow what what kind
of progress i just made on that
you'll shock yourself
and you make it a lot less scary it
gives you the confidence and motivation
to keep going
believe
those are watching you like the video
thumbs up below i love seeing them come
in and i want to hear what you have to
think do you have confidence you have
issues with your confidence can i answer
a question for you please leave it below
in the comments section it's the best
part of my day of seeing those comments
come in so thank you so much guys and
i'll see you soon
you